16 83 s'il vous plaît 32-28 s'il vous
plaît
je dis les gars c'est plus ma jument et
elle a tout gagné jamais vu ici il
possède à cheval de course possédait il
a presque tout perdu
un peu juste au niveau trésorerie mais à
la place j'ai apporté une belle bavette
d'aloyau séjour j'attendais un petit
quelque chose qui me donne envie de me
lever le matin je vais élever à cheval
de course c'est une pure folie ce sont
en général des professionnels avisés et
aisée qui se lancent dans ce genre
d'aventuré je pense savoir comment faire
vingt personnes d'un village chacun met
dix livres par semaine pendant deux ans
quand le cheval sera né on en sera tous
les heureux propriétaires et à parts
égales de surcroît y est capable
d'élever un cheval de course alors je
veux en être ces dix livres par semaine
car me abrutis
trouvez-vous de dream alliance il est
notre rêve à tous et on s'est associé
pour le réaliser donc prémalliance
[Musique]
accroche toi tu es bon pour être
champion il est admis sur le champ de
courses adressée balma temps réel
[Musique]
si fière de toi pour toi rien semble
impossible
[Musique]
on a perdu nos boulots notre communauté
et même notre fierté quand il est arrivé
il nous a rappelé combien la vie est
belle quand on a de l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]